foreign
this is talk TV
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored a
stunning exclusive interview and a
dramatic Story of Survival
foreign
Khan on his extraordinary escape from
assassins
my right leg uh Buckle under me because
it was hit by these bullets and
initially it felt like a burning
sensation
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored well good evening from London
welcome to Piers Morgan on censored
tonight a dramatic and exclusive
interview with one of the most explosive
figures in global politics
he's the world-class Sportsman who
became a world leader and just five days
ago he cheated death Imran Khan there's
none across the planet as a legendary
cricketer as captain of Pakistan he was
a nation's hero before sensationally
becoming his prime minister earlier this
year he was ouster from power and what
he insists was a conspiracy and last
week rallying supporters for a March
from the capital and a stunning
political comeback this happened
[Music]
well that gun attack on his Convoy kill
one person and injured at least 10 more
a suspect was arrested after a supporter
overpowered him tonight for the first
time on UK television Imran Khan tells
the full dramatic story of surviving his
assassination attempt
in slow motion I felt and I honestly
even when I was lying there with these
three bullets I felt I'd been saved
he Reveals His fiery views on the plot
to kill him
the more my party got popular the more
we sort of swept the by-elections the
more danger to my life
his chilling fears for the future
people are so worried my in my country I
right now I've never had this feeling
before because they know that the guys
who missed this time will try again
and his word it's on prime minister
Rishi sunak and racism in the UK
I never thought that a day would come
and Britain would be ready for an Indian
origin prime minister
it's a remarkable interview we cover
lots of ground and I began with a very
sincere and heartfelt message
well I'm joined Now by Imran Khan Imran
great to see you and it really is great
to see you
um how are you it's my first question
recovering uh beers I I've got had three
bullets taken out from my right leg and
some strap Lord my left leg
so one of the bullets has uh fractured
my shin bone so that's that would take a
bit of time but I'm recovering glad that
it could have been a lot worse
you know it was back in June that we
spoke and I asked you directly about how
you felt about the threat of
assassination you were aware of a plot
then to try and kill you when I entered
politics I actually had conquered my
fear of dying but when that moment
happens when you start to hear gunfire
what on Earth was that like for you
know uh
first it sounded like firecrackers
and then you know my right leg uh Buckle
under me because it was hit by these
bullets and initially it felt like a
burning sensation
and as I was falling there was another
there were two Shooters one was on the
left side
and he would have got me on the top body
but he was only 20 feet away so this uh
very brave person in the crowd went
after him and and went for the gun so
the gun went down uh you know this uh
pistol which was on automatic and when
it went down it hit my legs so when I
fell there was another shooter in front
and when he fired the bullets went over
me so as I was following these bullets
were going over me only you Imran could
be slightly smiling as you tell the
story I mean to me this sounds utterly
horrifying this is two people trying to
kill you
uh it was a plot look uh pears I told
you when I spoke to you in June that
there was this plot uh why did they want
to kill me because when the whole
conspiracy to change my government and
uh and this regime change
they expected that the party would just
wither away or it'll take years for it
to recover in fact what happened was
that unprecedented public reaction and
you had millions of people coming on the
streets the next day to protest against
the regime change so I think from then
onwards
what they expected was that my
popularity or my party would go down in
fact it went up that's when my life
became uh came in danger so there was a
first plot four people uh decided to
bump me off I I I found out because
remember I was head of the intelligence
agencies for three and a half years when
I was the Prime Minister
so I I named those people in a video and
announced that if anything happens to me
these four people would be exposed
they're powerful people
and then because of that it protected me
but then the party became even stronger
75 percent of all by-elections were
swept by my party against all the
parties put together so 11 parties on
one ticket and my party on and we we got
75 of the election so that's when the
second plot came in now this plot was
to have me bumped off by a religious
fanatic and it would be that I had
committed Plus for me so this plot
started uh in September I and I found
out again how I find out is from within
the intelligence agencies because people
all by what is going on here so there is
they uh I found out I again went on the
media on public rallies two public
rallies on 24th of September and 7th of
October and said that they will they are
preparing the grounds
uh and it was a media first which
prepared the ground and I know who was
behind it and then they would have some
exactly what happened to me someone
would claim I'm a religious fanatic he's
offended my uh uh uh uh uh sensitivities
about religion and he would shoot me so
this was again it's on record the whole
script I I announced in a public two
public rallies uh and that's what
happened that's what they did Imran
notwithstanding the fact that you you
had these threats on your life to
actually go out and face big crowds week
in week out month in month out
you know I know you from your past as a
Fearless cricketer this is a whole
different world thinking that somebody
may be there wanting to take your life
how did you deal with that how did it
make you feel
there's when they impose this
a government of crooks and let me tell
you the whole country knows it's a
government of two families who've been
stealing money from this country who've
been in jail their books written on
their corruption I came into politics to
fight these two families so when they
brought them back through a conspiracy
and imposed them on us I decided that I
was not going to sit at home and that's
when I went out in the public and for
six months I was campaigning now during
these six months frequently I would get
this message that you know there's going
to be a Bomb Blast or your suicide
attacker or your life is a threat and so
I took a conscious decision do I accept
uh
these Crooks to rule over us just
because I'm my life is at threat or
should I believe as I believe in God as
a Muslim that life and death is it in
his hands so I I took a decision I said
look whatever happens I know that
there's these big guns are threatened
this uh uh what should I say mafias are
threatened if I and the more my party
got popular the more we sort of swept
the by-elections the more danger to my
life now when the first plot which I
mentioned earlier the second plot
was
um you know I I knew I as I said in a
public rally I spoke about it now
as I was falling when the bullets hit my
leg and I fell and these bullets went
over my head
and I then I felt my body because when I
was when the shooting stopped I felt
sort of way and I felt my leg was hit I
was numb but I checked my top body then
I realized that the almighty had saved
me because there's no way I should have
been saved because there were two
Shooters a one very close 20 feet the
other one is right in the building in
front there's no way I should have
survived it but you know
that it reinforced my faith in in the
Almighty
I mean it wasn't astonishing Escape
you know by all you know if you look at
the footage you just assume that in that
scenario your chances of survival are
very small
Europe is this guy I mean the hero
they're two Heroes that uh that were
that saved me one was this this guy when
he saw him taking this pistol out
this guy immediately went for his hand
and you know when he uh when he tried to
grab the gun the gun went down and
that's how I I was saved because I would
have got all the bullets on my top body
so they went at my legs and then you
know uh this other guy also tried to he
had two magazines still so if this guy
hadn't intervened the guy would have
fixed two magazines and and kept
shooting and then you know when the
other guy hit hit us because it hit my
leg I collapsed so the bullets went over
my head I in slow motion I felt and I
honestly even when I was lying there
with these three bullets I felt I'd been
saved
I mean truly remarkable the the first uh
guy who raced to your rescue who you can
see in the pictures pushing the
Shooter's Gun up
um and then the second guy you see
trying to run towards him then he as he
pushes him away he falls over and very
sadly it transpires he lost his life
this man really gave his life to save
you how do you feel about him
he had come to this rally with his two
kids
and and so he with two kids there he
went for the gunman who shot him in the
face now that was really tragic I mean
that really touched not just me the
whole of the country because there was
this picture of him lying there and
these his kids sitting either side
trying to wake him up you know it was uh
I think that was uh probably
the most uh awful sight I've seen so I
called his family I saw met his kids and
we have decided to take care of them for
the rest of their lives
yeah I mean I think that's that's a very
honorable thing to do remarkable courage
they showed
um you also Imran you have kids back
here in the UK and your ex-wife Jemima
was on Twitter saying how relieved that
they all were uh to see that you'd
survived this but you know in those
moments you must also you're a father
you know what were your thoughts once
you knew you'd survived about your sons
did you did you want to speak to them
quickly because obviously they would
they would hear about it perhaps before
you could even talk to them
okay
I did I well you know
I had I was driven from there or almost
took me two hours to get to the hospital
which I built you know which is
the the best for for me the best
hospital in Pakistan because three times
I've been treated there and I'm quite
scared of needles and stuff like that so
I went to the hospital two hours drive
the moment I got there then I spoke to
my sons and of course I spoke to my wife
uh both of them my wife actually was a
remarkable you know she was almost she
was you know the fact that I was saved
she was quite relieved but my boys were
sort of quite worried and I hope to see
them soon I mean are they Keen for you
now to stay out of the public eye I've
got three sons in their 20s I would
imagine if something similar happened to
me the first thing they would want is an
assurance from their father that I
wouldn't be putting myself over the
parapet I know you and I know how
committed you are to this I'm sure you
want to continue but is that is that on
your mind your sons and how they feel
foreign
dog mode
my older son was very sensitive
so when I when they were about eight
nine years old my oldest son that's when
he used to worry a lot you know and he
always wanted me out of politics but you
know I
you know I feel
that you know we human beings have a
responsibility to our society and this
is the spiritual way of life there are
two ways one is material yourself the
other is a spiritual and some 30 years
ago when I went on the spiritual path
that's the only reason I came into
politics because I realized I had a
responsibility
being so privileged in this country so
therefore
you have to have faith and faith is in
God and the one verse in the Quran that
on
it's when the when the almighty decides
it's not one minute before one minute
after that's your time
so when I was lying on that uh you know
with these bullets I knew I had been
saved so it's so easy you don't
understand I've sat in a cancer hospital
I built this hospital for five years my
office was there I saw healthy people
coming in going in six months or some
being saved so life and death I feel you
know we worry too much that we have
control over it we don't
it's an in almighty's hands
what is going to be your response in a
minute are you just going to continue
putting yourself out there going back on
protest marches continuing to fight your
cause will nothing change
well no the moment my leg heals I'm I'm
going to be out again but you know
people are so worried my in my country I
right now I've never had this feeling
before because they know that the guys
who missed this time will try again
public in Pakistan knows this because
these are powerful people
and they also are worried that if now if
Whenever there are elections my party is
going to sweep the elections all
opinions
polls surveys all these by-elections
they reflect that my party now is the
most popular party in Pakistan so
because of this threat and worried if I
win
they they are going to try again we all
know it so I've doubled my security at
my house
I mean you are a remarkably phlegmatic
character Imran and again I go back to
when I watched you play cricket and he
faced the fastest Bowlers probably the
world has ever seen and you did it with
swashbuckling Panache and and audacity
and courage but it's one thing facing
fast Bowlers in a cricket match quite
another going back out after people have
tried to shoot you dead and know that
they may try again
uh were you getting this strength of
character from
Bears faith I have uh you know I never
really had faith in my life till much
later I had end of my cricketing career
and it's very clear there are two ways
of spending your life one is you know
where you're conscious
the spiritual life which is that there
is a purpose to existence and how how
much the almighty gives you the more
responsibility he puts on you so that's
one way and the other is living for
yourself which is very easy I mean even
from after Cricket I never had to work
after that I could easily live a very
comfortable life so it was a conscious
decision some 30 years ago you're very
passionate about who you think uh
ordered this and executed it but who do
you trust in Pakistan to properly
impartially investigate this
well
let me tell you that the institution of
the army people are extremely upset what
has happened
so it's not as if the whole institution
is involved you know this I believe that
this intelligence officer I know there
are two accomplice and remember the the
intelligence services are under the
prime minister so there's the Prime
Minister and the interior minister so
the only hope I have is that if the
Chief Justice of Pakistan if he asserts
himself
if he takes if he now has this inquiry
conducted through the Supreme Court you
know gets uh the people involved of
repute already there's a case there's a
there was the best investigative
journalist in Pakistan arshad Sharif he
was by you know he was
talking about this regime change and he
was always
backing my point of view he was the
number one journalist he was hounded out
of Pakistan the same Intelligence
Officers were involved he was threatened
he left Pakistan for Dubai he went to
Kenya he was assassinated in Kenya and
as for the shooters one of them we know
was arrested the second one that you
claim was shooting has not been arrested
what do you think happened to that
second shooter
I think the second shooter is at large
you know it's not just me I mean I these
bullets because this shooter was on the
left the bullets that were going over my
head and others and in fact though
eyewitnesses who saw him fighting from a
building so we have no idea and the
police hasn't registered a case against
the other one they've only blamed this
so because this shooter
fits in with the with the narrative that
it was a religious fanatic by the way
he's not a religious fanatic because the
social media guys went to his his home
and and discovered this guy didn't even
pray so but he was a very professional
shooter you know he shot with this
automatic if you I have done pistol
shooting and if you shoot it on
automatic it's very difficult unless
you're used to it to control it because
it goes up but he had complete control
so he was a trained guy and the other
one I've we you know we're a hundred
percent sure that he was the one who was
the rail you know who would have been
the but if I if I had if he missed me he
would have got me
remarkable stuff from Imran Khan and
part two will be after the break also
later the program kiss front man Gene
Simmons well we're talking about the U.S
midterm elections and whether it's time
for the Republicans to dump Trump
becoming next more from my exclusive
interview with Imran Khan who just
survived an assassination attempt we
talk about Richie sunac mother of the UK
is a racist country
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Khan we talk about British prime
minister Rishi soon act and what the
first Hindu British PM says about Martin
Britain and a warning there's some
strong language here
one of the other major issues right now
is Free Speech we've got Elon Musk has
bought Twitter and is determined as he
says to bring back Free Speech we've
also seen in August uh the author Salman
Rusty attacked on stage and nearly
murdered suffered horrific injuries
obviously that is a controversial
subject in Pakistan Salman Rushdie and
his book Satanic Verses what is your
reaction to what happened to Salmon
Rushdie
I've already given my reaction pairs as
you quite rightly have pointed out it
has a uh especially in our country it's
extremely controversial
I mean is it so controversial you don't
want to say anything
uh you know I have enough issues right
now to uh
to deal with rather than uh you know
have
other issues on my head
I mean I I and I understand it but there
were a lot of people who obviously would
have felt that Free Speech should mean
free speech that will happen to Summer
Rushdie was a consequence of a a fat
while being put on him and somebody then
executing that fat one yeah
because look you know I've commented on
that issue and uh there was a big
backlash because people don't understand
this and I'm talking about where I'm
sitting right now so where you are from
I understand your point of view but
where I am uh you know it is just going
to cause as it did before when when I
commented on it so uh let me just pass
on this
I mean just as a final observation you
mean it would put your life in even more
Danger
should you continue to comment on it
look I have enough challenges already
I understand
let me ask you about the U.S midterm
elections which have just taken place uh
unusually and well I think surprisingly
the Democrats and Joe Biden didn't get
the heavy losses that they were
anticipating and that everybody else was
anticipating what does that tell you
about the state of American politics
what is your view now of the Biden
Administration I know that you blame
them for what happened to you earlier
this year do you hope to have a better
relationship with them going forward
look there's yellow
who would not want to have good
relationship with the United States it's
a superpower and from Pakistan's point
of view uh we export the highest exports
out to the US and the most powerful and
the richest Pakistani expatriate
Community are the Pakistani American
in the U.S so
you know it's Unthinkable that you would
not want to have good relationship with
the U.S there's only one issue I have
you know Pakistan and U.S relationship
has been like uh
transactional Master Slave relationship
when Pakistan is needed you know we
serve a purpose and then and we degrade
ourselves by the way I don't blame the
US that much I think we allow ourselves
to be used like a tissue paper and it's
humiliating as a Pakistani that you know
we were we got independence the same
time as India India has you know a very
dignified relationship with the US you
know the every country wants to protect
its interests India stands for its
interests but what Pakistan has done is
we've been like slaves we've been used
like for instance the war on terror
Pakistan had nothing to do with the with
9 11. we were the the head of the uh our
state claimed that they were forced into
this war by the U.S because the U.S
would bomb us into stone age we ended up
losing 80 000 pakistanis in a war that
had nothing to do with us so that's what
I object to I want a relationship like
India has with the US
we have in the UK now the first uh prime
minister who's come from an Asian
background Indian Heritage Rishi sunak
uh you spent a lot of time in the UK
were you were you surprised by that were
you pleasantly surprised that we finally
gone for a non-white prime minister
I'm uh I I am surprised because you know
my what I had you know and I remember I
went there as an 18 year old and then
there were these skinheads around and
they would beat up any one Asian they
would beat them up and call them Pakis
so I saw that uh you know the beginning
and racism was very obvious at that time
as a cricketer as a young cricketer I
used to see field racism in county
cricket but when I became faster in a
fast bowler then of course if there was
racism it was behind my back it wasn't
on the cricket field but in the in the
beginning I were there would be racist
comments on right on your face but I saw
the change take place but I must confess
I never thought that a day would come
and Britain would be ready for an Indian
origin prime minister and I think it's
very positive
you know he's a massive Cricket fan he
goes and has Nets at the oval
um he and I said are you a defensive
bats when he went absolutely not front
foot very much in the Imran Khan
category of batsman by the sound of it
um are you comforted that we have a
leader in this country who's a cricket
fan I always think they're on a
different level of human being Superior
uh uh look it's uh Britain I mean
whoever becomes the prime minister right
now you know he has to have the ability
to take pressure because it's going
through a I feel probably one of the
I mean ever since I've uh you know been
in touch with Britain 70s there were
these Gold Miner strikes and and so on
strikes but since then I think this is
probably the toughest time the country
is going through so it's not going to be
easy he needs to be it'll be a baptism
of fire for uh yeah do you know have you
met him
no no I've never met him would you like
to
yes one day uh yes I would
I want to hang on a positive note Emery
it's been a riveting interview as always
with you I've particularly given what
happened to you
um the T20 World Cup literally moments
before I sat down for this interview
Pakistan had a fantastic win over New
Zealand and have roared into the T20
final well they may end up playing
England
a repeat of 92 World Cup because we beat
New Zealand in the semi-finals and then
we played England in the final uh yes
it's a country celebrating right now
it's a it's as you say it's not been
easy uh probably not even in England but
it's not been easy here and this win has
given all of us a great boost so we're
all looking forward to the final and I
think our team looks good I'm I think we
we might just win the final well let's
not be 250 here I'm sorry but all boys
are coming for you and just to remind
you we also recently won another world
cup so we've got a bit of a bit of
trophy in the cabinet it's fantastic to
see you I really I started that way and
I really mean it when I first heard
about what had happened you always fear
the absolute worst in my heart sunk
particularly given the conversation we'd
had just a few months ago so it's great
to see you alive and well and recovering
well and I wish you all the very best
and thank you very much indeed for
joining me
can't think of many people in the world
that would give an interview quite that
way so relaxed just five days after
attempted assassination where Shooters
ran towards him with guns blazing quite
a remarkable character Imran Khan on a
cricket field and in the political Arena
well still to come it's depicting the
Scandal hit Royals and all their gory
details crude sensationalism Sharon
Osborne will be here on whether the
crown has gone too far plus the Red Wave
turned into a bit of a red trickle had
the brakes been slammed on Trump's big
comeback his front man Gene Simmons on
the prospect of trump V Biden or will it
be DeSantis
we'll talk about that after the break as
well plus we're talking about this
complete and utter tool
the man who put the [ __ ] into Hancock
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back to Facebook I'll be talking
about the US midterm elections which had
some very unexpected results which might
mean bad news for Donald Trump uh and of
course it raises the question of who
will fight who in 2024 but let's just
get some reaction to that extraordinary
interview with Imran Khan joining me now
editor at large of the US Financial
Times Jillian Tech kiss front man Gene
Simmons Fox Nation host Tommy lahren and
talk to you presenter Charles for
probably the greatest ensembler I've had
in Piers pack history uh I think I'll
put that on the record so welcome to you
all Jillian I know you were watching
that Imran Khan interview with with
Fascination it was an extraordinary
interview to be doing just a few days
after Imran was nearly assassinated what
did you make of it
well I thought first of all to make the
obvious point it was very moving
um it's very refreshing to see a leader
who is so driven by a sense of higher
purpose and his points about the fact
that you know we never know when we're
going to meet our creator it can happen
anytime you know having Justice survived
an assassination attempt is indeed very
very moving for my money though one of
the most interesting points he made was
the relationship between Pakistan and
the US and his point that you know he
considers that India has a much more
grown-up mature relationship with the US
and Pakistan now you can argue with
that's true or not but the reality is it
underscores that Pakistan has
tremendously important GM political
significance right now and one thing
that the Pakistan government knew if
you're thinking about is how it can or
cannot project that position effectively
on the world stage yeah we completely
agree turn to the midterms Tommy Laren
if I interviewed you yesterday you would
have been bursting with positivity the
Red Wave is coming it's going to be a
tsunami well it turned out to be a bit
of a of a damp squib trickle what
happened
Hey listen uh yes we did expect there to
be a bigger Red Wave than what we're
seeing but you know it's not over till
it's over we're hoping to get majorities
it's still in play we're gonna take the
gavel away from Nancy Pelosi we still
have a chance to win a majority in the
Senate so it's not over until it's over
I will say this though um the only race
that really really shocked me was
Pennsylvania the fact that
pennsylvanians chose John fetterman a
man that whether you want to discuss is
stroke or not or you feel like that's
off the table the man cannot articulate
himself and that is one of the key rules
in being a senator that you have to
articulate yourself so that happening in
Pennsylvania shocked me I am befuddled
by it but everything else I think I'm
still very ecstatic take a look at
Florida take a look at who I hope will
be our next Presidential nominee Ronda
Santos and how well he did with
Republicans with independence with
Hispanics Miami-Dade a county that we
never thought would really go red went
red and that is because of Rhonda Santos
and the way that he managed Florida so I
am still very excited I'm very energized
and we are looking forward to some
unfinished business being finished in
2020. well I've just written a column
for the New York Post actually saying
exactly that but I've also concluded
it's time for the GOP to dump Trump so
Tommy are you dumping Trump as we speak
Trump is always going to be important to
our party his endorsement is still
important to our party I know that some
of his endorsements didn't shake out the
way they should have quite frankly we
had some candidates like Dr Oz that
weren't the best candidates we could
have put forward so we have to be honest
about that now we're not going to dump
Trump but I think if we're smart and we
really want to win because our country
depends on it we go in the Rhonda
stantis Direction I am a little bit
upset that Donald Trump has made the
race more about himself than about
America First it has to be America First
it has to be policy first Ronda Santos
does that he is my choice he is my pick
I hope that Donald Trump steps back
stands out of the way and lets Rhonda
santis take the throne okay uh Gene
Simmons
um you're a kind of well I guess you are
a republican would you identify still as
a Republican
no I would not I have a like tens of
millions of Americans are sick and tired
of the far left as well as the far right
and I don't like how either party is
behaving and I wish for the good old
days where you can politely disagree and
sit down and Hammer stuff out it Bears
noting that the currency whether it's
the paper currency or you know the coins
have two completely different sides and
yet they're still part of the same coin
it's time for everybody to wake up and
uh smell the coffee the way people are
behaving with each other is childlike
and the deniers and the far left way too
Progressive look one second you you wake
up in Wisconsin and I love Middle
America because you know my life was
made by people who sometimes disagree
with my point of view I love them I
understand them one second you grow up
in a nuclear family the next second
you're being told you can't make a bake
a cake for somebody uh you know who has
a different sexual orientation or a
different on religious grounds then it
goes all the way up to the uh Supreme
Court it's a crazy crazy time
and as your comment I don't want to jump
subjects but regarding Mr Trump we both
know them to some extent yeah I would
never rule the gentleman out I think
he's a street fighter and he will go and
if Mr DeSantis who I think has a decent
shot at grabbing some headlines and
making an impact decides to go all
you're going to see Mr Trump go after
him and he's already done you know what
Jesus
you and I were on Celebrity Apprentice
the first season of It in America uh I
don't want to remind you that I won
actually I probably won only because you
quit after a few years well I'd like to
respect that I'd like to respectfully
remind you I had to I won immediately
within five minutes that's true of I
became the captain yeah and I had to
then find out that I had to go to
Australia on a tour and then between you
and I I had to politely and somehow very
fast get myself fired off do you really
believe I was fired that quickly no I
actually know that you had to leave and
I was very pleased to see the back of
you because I saw you as my main threat
however here's my question to you
um knowing Trump as we do if he had
himself in that boardroom Following last
night I think he'd fire himself
and I think that's the point the
Republican Party have reached but
they're going to work out where they
want to go you know can they go with
Trump uh you know Biden is saying he may
run again he'll be in his 80s
go with DeSantis who is nearly half his
age full of young youthful energy he
seems much calmer more focused you know
I just think to me it seems a sensible
play for the Republicans
if I was an avowed Republican and I am
not I would go with Mr Trump because I
know exactly what he's going to do he's
going to if Mr Biden is running uh he's
going to play dirty and perhaps he
should and show footage for TV ads
showing Mr Biden falling downstairs
repeatedly and uh stammering over words
and stuff like it's not even about the
issues uh he's going to win points just
to show that the gentleman who's
currently the president may be too old
to serve and he's gonna he's gonna win
on that level do I think Mr Biden is
going to lose to Mr Trump if they're on
head to head yes I do I may not agree
with the point of view and this is not
about how I feel because remember there
are curtains that prevent anybody from
finding out what your business is it's
your your own private business who you
vote for but my assessment is that Mr
Trump can handily beat Mr Biden in an
election because Mr Biden is going to be
respectable my guess is to try the
trumpet is not well my guess is neither
Trump nor Biden will actually run in
2024 we'll see uh Sharon as my
residential political expert on this
panel uh I want to focus not on the
American politics but on UK politics and
Matt Hancock are dearly beloved recent
Health secretary who is now munching
kangaroo testicles in a reality
television program in Australia we have
a clip of him already down and dirty
let's have a look
oh oh there's a load of slurry just
pulled on my head wait are you still
carrying on yeah wait for me okay come
down the tunnel one minute gone
so here there's a left turn or straight
on which way do you want me to go which
way do I want you to well I don't mind
if I don't know
Sharon is he the man who's put the [ __ ]
into Hancock
oh definitely
definitely but a little one
I mean it is completely ridiculous we
have a guy who was a senior cabinet
minister and a pandemic who calls
potentially thousands of lives with his
woeful handling of the pandemic
certainly in the first phase and now
he's raking it in in nearly half a
million pounds to go and and do this in
a jungle in Australia rather than serve
his constituents
well I made the guy obviously is
desperate to be a celebrity and
um he's going for it isn't he it's it's
it's you know nothing nothing surprises
me with anyone anymore and especially in
politics but um you know he's very
thirsty for celebrity isn't he I think
he is and maybe he's looked at what's
happened in America and thinks that
celebrity now can take you a long way in
politics people like it in fact the
worst you behave the better
yeah
with his little [ __ ] I don't think so
Jillian said on a serious Point here
what do you make from across from across
the point upon Jillian looking over here
at what Hancock is doing what do you
make of it
well these days it's not really a beauty
parade when it comes to which countries
have rational sensible governments it's
more like an ugly parade
um and it does seem pretty shocking to
have you know a former government
Minister on a reality TV show where not
for the fact there's so much of Politics
as being like a reality TV show even
without some kind of trip to a remote
jungle
um so I think people on this side of the
Atlantic are just rolling their eyes and
going yes he had another sign of just
how weird
um British politics have become and of
course they're now contemplating the
ultimate political reality TV star
Donald Trump potentially making a
comeback
um so the wheel will come potentially
full circle yes I mean I I strongly
agree
yeah I strongly agree with what you said
in terms of the dump Trump Point
um I think the clear message from the
midterm results we've had so far we
don't had all them yet
um some really crucial results yet to
come but the clearer message from the
results is that the scientists achieved
a storming victory in Florida really
very very dramatic
um and Trump's candidates for the most
part did not perform particularly well
um what happened to Dr Oz was very
revealing because remember Dr Oz
basically managed to knock out another
very very competent candidate as
Republican nominee before Dave McCormack
um they've essentially lost because of
the Trump support for Dr Oz
a lot of people saying today
I want to come back and talk quickly
about the crown which drops tonight is
it a force for dramatic good or is it a
disgusting assault on the royal family
we'll discuss that in a moment
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
or season five of the crown drops today
in the flagship Netflix series hasn't
pulled any punches accused of crude
sensationalism by them Judy Dench this
guide his malicious nonsense by former
British prime minister Sir John Major
who's portrayed by Johnny Lee Miller in
the show and coming to soon after the
death of the late Queen many think this
Series has gone too far and is coming
out too soon
in light of the events of the last 12
months
perhaps I have more to reflect on than
most
[Music]
have Royal scandals damaged the
country's reputation
I won't go quietly I'll battle till the
end
how did it come to this
we're joined by my super Packers and
malcolor and Sharon Osborne I gotta be
honest I know it may be wrong and I
can't wait to watch this I'm going to
get back home tonight pour a glass of
wine and get stuck in
um yeah I will too but at the same time
I think that people have to remember
that this is TV and it's about ratings
and I don't think it will be respectful
I I don't think you know they will
obviously rewrite history and
um it's just about ratings it's meant to
shock it's meant to be disrespectful I
think just to get the audience to watch
yeah and Gene Simmons I mean you would
have had a lot of stuff written and said
about you over the years as a big rock
star
um when it comes to dramatization should
there be any rules really does it matter
ultimately and invariably in other big
words like gymnasium no look I'm
delusional I think I'm kind of a big
deal so when I come home I'm used to the
wifey going oh it's you know they'll
stop the world here he is and my
daughter Sophie but if they're watching
if they're watching the crown or
anything to do with Royals all I get is
I'm going for heaven's sakes put it on
pause you can rewind it watch it later
so you know I gotta sit there like you
know and watch it even though they can
rewind it and see I'm home I'm here I'm
kind of a big deal
tell me later on are you as enthralled
by every juicy bone that we gnaw on with
this royal family or could you get knock
air less
Hey listen I think that people love
drama I think that people are so used to
watching reality television that they
need their scripted television to match
just how dramatic their reality
television is and I don't think that
there are any rules anymore and quite
frankly I don't think that there should
be we should be adult enough to know
what actually happened what actually
happened in history and separate fact
from fiction it's not people that make
television or make movies job to educate
us on what is true and what is not we
should be able to do that for ourselves
we are adults I think they should have
fun with it it is about ratings but then
again isn't that what television is
about isn't that what streaming is about
make it more dramatic do what you got to
do to get the eyeballs I don't think
there's anything wrong with it Jillian
te I mean there is a body of thought
that this is too soon after the Queen's
death it's insensitive a lot of the
people are still alive but of course you
could also point out that Prince Harry
will doubtless be outraged and yet he
himself has done a massive deal with
Netflix to spill his own beans what's
the difference
yeah there's plenty of stuff coming out
already about the royal family so I
think it's a bit ridiculous to say that
you couldn't be able to make those kind
of um film this kind of fictionalized
series the problem I have with this is
really about the labeling and they
should come with a very big sign saying
it is fiction slapped all over it in big
letters at the top
um you know if they were making a
documentary um attempting to do a proper
piece of history that would be one thing
but this is fiction and we live in an
age where unfortunately people have
problems distinguishing fiction from
non-fiction and where inevitably given
how recent these events are and given
the fact they are basically using real
life characters all over the place
people will think this is actually
documentary and so it's really about the
labeling that I think the real question
and debate should be right now yeah well
I think we should carry a label on this
show uh especially with this Super PAC
that we are very much uncensored on this
show and you have all been magnificently
unsensitive thank you you so much for
joining me Jillian Tech Gene Simmons
Tommy lahren Sharon Osborne what a pack
what a pack thank you very much indeed
to all of you and remember whatever
you're up to Keep It Uncensored that's
all good to know good night Jordan
Peterson tomorrow night
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]